[Music]
welcome back let's find out if we got
anything wrong this week
for that we go to our show's ombudsman
steve phoenix jr
steve uh how's your father steve phoenix
senior
oh well greg uh he's actually the fact
checker at cnn so he's incredibly busy
these days
oh very good but first up let's hear
your comments from monday
about the body mass index director mike
lights camera faction we have shifted
the bmi
definition so that everybody is obese
like by definition
well looks like you're partially right
okay
according to the nih and the cdc the
threshold for being considered
overweight
was lowered in 1998 from a bmi of 27.8
to 25. so not everyone as you say is
considered obese
but the change brought u.s definitions
in line with the world health
organization and those guys are never
wrong about anything
you have a fat face the bmi has been
widely criticized
uh and many feel that much like your
show it's outdated and overrated
we gotta move on greg we gotta move on
gotcha kat
kat uh let's listen to your comments
from monday on post pandemic friendships
magic mike hit it if you want to be
hot like look hot you actually really
need uglier friends
thank you thank you thank you finally we
come to it
well okay this is technically true but
morally wrong
oh i don't worry about that no no no
clearly not but it's actually a
cognitive bias known as the ugly friend
effect
and it's real according to a 2016 study
published in the journal of
psychological science
wow yeah no it's yeah and i speak the
truth
you go ahead you in this case you kind
of do and i agree with you
actually if we could let's show a pic of
my friend isaac
yeah we actually go clubbing together on
the weekends
all right yeah don't but we got to move
on
let's finish where it all began with my
man greg
greg let's take a look at what you said
tuesday about twitter trends
roll it mike here's an interesting fact
i learned today do you know that twitter
trends
are based on really small numbers
anywhere from twelve hundred
to nineteen hundred tweets over a six
hour period
can get a twitter trending that's
nothing
well uh social media analytics companies
can only
guess as to how twitter's trending
algorithm works because it isn't public
and this is fun i happen to find the
shoddy marketing site you got your
information from
fun fact the author of that research had
her twitter account suspended
there you go because she was telling the
truth she paid the price yeah
and in fact most twitter users see
trends tailored to them
which you know makes sense when i
borrowed your phone yesterday and saw
the top tweets were for platform shoes
[Laughter]
oh greg it looks like i'm being told i'm
out of time once again man so i gotta go
i'll see you next week okay
all right bye
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else